this is the second time in seven months
delaware farms has been forced to cull
its chickens
thirty thousand birds are being
destroyed just two weeks after sixty
three thousand dollars was spent to
restock the farm
it was very very diverse it was stating
for us and
very difficult to play so
we just have to come at the populated
them and all that so we really lost
so much so much
but we don't even know what to do now
last year bird flu
was the h9n2 virus
this year is the more lethal h5n1
variant which is difficult to control
24 hours ago
4 000 chickens were here now it's nearly
empty and even the fuel remaining will
have to be destroyed veterinary
officials say just one infraction is
enough reason to curl the entire farm
birds
and the rising number of deaths across
ghana warriors the government
we are having to
deal with it to try to minimize the cost
in terms of the
debts mortalities
is the highest
in the ten year the three the third one
we have all more than seven hundred
thousand beds which have either been put
down as a preventive measure to control
that spread or have been died out of the
infection
officials on the ground say the current
outbreak took them by surprise
considering the numbers so
we are a little bit overwhelmed because
of resources and
logistics and all that so in a way
most of the things are not
actually in place as we because we
didn't anticipate that this number of
best will be affected
ghana's neighbors
are reporting cases too
the eclipse unit has tried to search for
the search of infection we have trace it
to wild bath it is not conclusive we are
crazy to shortage of feed that people
were bringing in feed from neighboring
countries
many small farms have been forced out of
business the government says it will
soon start compensating farmers for
their losses
but while they wait for help
thousands of farm workers face uncertain
times about their future
ahmed idris al jazeera tema ghana